actually outside who is the
tenant that's moving in okay let's move
them in then
do you want to do the video though no
video we're going to do it or anytime
she'll like just call him in yeah yeah
okay let's meet him
okay did you join the feast yeah
what's happening my name is samuel leeds
i'm standing inside hmo
i'm with my good friends i'm pretty now
these guys are on the property investors
academy
tell us what happened because you had a
little bit of a nightmare with this
property didn't you
yeah um we we've done it up to an
amazing standard
it's beautiful so you'll see that soon
in this video
um but when we're shown people around
they're really loving it
uh however when it comes to committing
they just won't commit
well they're really loving it though or
they pretending to love it
it's it appeared as if they were really
loving because that'd be british culture
you know yeah oh isn't it fantastic i'll
call you back
i mean what so so we realized didn't we
that there was some things that were
going a little bit wrong
yeah that we've been now fixing and
seeing some changes
yeah so what we're going to do how many
how many rooms has this got so this has
got seven rooms
seven rooms so we're going to take you
through the property but we're going to
give you
seven tips about how to get tenants
quickly in your house you want to show
us the first room of course yeah
now ice love it
so all right rule number one tip one
of getting tenants through your property
quickly so
especially for this room it's important
to take really good photos
um as you can see this room's got
natural lighting so it's important to
take a photo from
each different angle so the tenant can
really get to see what the room
looks like from a different perspective
yeah true
so and you've done this for quite a
decent stand where quite a nice standard
did you
and also when you took on this property
you had a rent-free period didn't you
maybe you could talk a bit about that
pressure yeah yeah the
the this property was in a really bad
state it hadn't been lived in
for 18 months prior to that it had
students in it so you can imagine
the state of the property um so i
negotiated with the landlord a six-week
grace period
um i said i would be bringing the
property up to a really high standard
um and he agreed to that so
we thought we've got six weeks to do
this property um
and bring it up to a high standard but
it did end up taking us a little bit
longer didn't it yeah
yeah okay we'll show us the next room
this room's got stuff we've got a tenant
that is just
just moving in literally i caught the
action
right i arrived as things were all
happening yes
okay yeah so how much is this room
renting out for
so this room is renting out for 550
pounds uh a calendar month
yeah so yeah interesting i asked the
tenant i said to him
what did you like about the room and he
said he likes the color of it
you've got you've got matching you know
you've got the
the blue and feature walls go such a
long way because if it was just
completely white all around
or magnolia all around it just feels a
bit dingy doesn't it
so the fact that you just made it pop um
interesting that that's the reason that
he said
so okay so uh tip number one of the
seven tips of the seven rooms
is to take good pictures tip two tip two
is give them all the information up
front that's really really important
so um you know for example these rooms
don't have
ensuite bathrooms um and i know
that's um in high demand at the moment
so i wanted to tell people up front
beforehand before they view the property
that they don't have um ensuite bathroom
rooms but the ratio is two to one to a
bathroom yeah so it's not too bad at all
right and so in other words there's no
point someone get into a property
wasting your
time wasting their time you're booking
views
and they're like oh i didn't know it
looked like this yeah so how do you do
that how do you
show people up front exactly what
they're expecting to get to
yeah so there's a video of the whole
property um
on spare room and it shows the
individual bathrooms
yeah shows that they're not attached to
the bedrooms and
so when people come in they come in to
secure it
they're not coming to have a look to see
what it looks like they know already
what it looks like
yeah right if you enjoy the video so far
like the video like the video
alright next room room three okay
nice so this is room three very very
nice
and this room has this gone yet um
no this one's still available yeah
interesting as well tip three
in room for it i'm gonna share this one
because tell us what you were doing when
i was like
no when i found out what because you
called me and you said
well you're on the on the 365 mastermind
session you said i got seven words
haven't rented out one room yes getting
loads of viewings
not happening and i was like okay i said
either the property sucks
yeah or you do something wrong the
property is
clearly decent and went through it and
it turns out that you weren't interested
in a little wrong
yes what were you doing i was showing
them every single room in the house
yeah so it was it was evident that no
one had taken any of the rooms correct
um so people i guess were then thinking
is there something wrong with this house
none of the rooms have gone
you're right so if you've got a brand
new house i said they're pretty i
said i said don't show them every room
just just show them one
or two rooms and then and then just look
this is the room that's available
because they're all pretty similar
anyway if you take them in all the rooms
you're going to confuse them if you
confuse them you lose them
so tip number three is if you've got
lots of rooms just take them in one or
two
not all the rooms because also when you
give people too much choice
they don't go for anything so but nice
nice running all right number four
has this room gone this room has gone
cool
when when's the
[Music]
so tip four room four what happened so
uh
basically samuel came in just as we were
showing this tenant around
and um he was really interested in each
room
but um he didn't he wasn't too sure
so what simon told me was to basically
in front of him
tell him that he was really interested
so hold on just to take context
who did i pretend to be you tend to be a
potential tenant
right so i came around the house they're
showing a tenant round and i thought
rather than me
just be like oh i'm samuel lee's their
mentor or whatever i'll pretend to be a
tenant i had darwin on the video with
the video we forgot
so we're like just so we're looking
around bear in mind these guys have only
shown them two rooms now
not all the rooms what happens is when
you show one or two rooms that's good
but block
viewings we created a block viewing we
didn't plan this
we manufactured this this was just a bit
spontaneous
but what happened as a result of the
block viewing effect
um immediately he he was really
interested
and he said to mom and straight the way
that yeah he wants the room so
it's basically put demand on him but
also pretty is what could you
could you tell how he was at first and
then when i was like
i want to take i want to take that room
like tell what happened
yeah so i i asked him more than once i
said
so are you interested do you like it and
he said yeah i need to think about it i
need to think about it
but um so i kind of insisted and said
but do you want to put deposit down and
i really need to think about
it and then kyle came in the room and
said um
well um have you signed up to any of the
rooms because
the other potential tenant that's here
really likes the room
i didn't really like the room it was
true we weren't lying or anything but
then what did he say well as soon as he
thought i was interested
as soon as he thought samuel was
interested he said yes
i'll take that room and i said well
which one is it and this
is the very room that you wanted to take
boom literally 20 minutes to go
so we need to just wait for a little bit
before we put this video out we'll give
it a few weeks
in case he sees it goes oh
but listen this is this is just basic
sales skills yeah money doesn't come
from property money comes from people
and until you know how to talk to people
until you know how to sell
you know in fact let's get let's go tip
five and i'm gonna talk about i'm gonna
share this next tip
very nice see they're all quite similar
though aren't they
they are seeing seven of these is not
going to do you any favors no
it's confusing it is so tip five which
is what i said to these guys last week
is i said
you need to actually close your
prospective
tenure this is sales everything is sales
so don't just show you're turning around
and then just go now get back to me you
can actually close the video just like
when are you thinking of moving in there
on parliament in a couple of weeks
alright great so which room do you like
best
oh um this one all right great so what's
going to happen i heard you say it
so what's going to happen now man if you
sat down right
you sat down what's going to happen now
then is
we're going to have to go through the
referencing and it
before he knows it he's in why because
you led him to the sale
you know unfortunately people are stupid
and people are like sheep
now they are stupid because why would
you not go for a room just because
there's six others that are empty
doesn't make any sense if you like the
room you like the room because you think
oh
no one wants it it's not true if you
just lead
you know if you just really and also
people are like sheep
just because i was there saying i'm
interested in the
i think he takes the right yeah you've
got to master the game of sales
so this is room five yes what do you
think though amazing do you feel more
confident knowing how to sell
absolutely absolutely brilliant okay
yeah all right let's go to room six
this is my room now this one this is my
room because i like the chair
oh and i like the balcony wow look at
this
and this room is gone the shoe's
so tip number six is referring friends
so
it's important to refer friends as if
you have people who are
the same same friendship groups you're
more likely to have a
cleaner house and better better rules
within that do you mean refer your
friends
just in general my friends or tenants
within the house as well
yeah that's a good point and you can
also incentivize tenants so you can say
hey if you can find any of your friends
that will want to move in we'll pay you
50 pounds
before you know it if you've got two or
three rooms filled in the seven bed
house
if everyone just recommends one or two
friends to move in you've got a full
house
if that happened yeah it did yeah
it's two of them so the the tenant that
just moved in
he referred the one that came to view
the property
just as you arrived right so um so all
of this kind of comes together you know
referring people
selling block viewings great good room
right we're going to the last room and
you're going to share the last tip
which was a game changer for these guys
and it's so
so simple so let's check out the last
room all right so tip number seven
go ahead okay so tip number seven is
renewing the spare room at
and this was a game changer for me i
hadn't i hadn't even realized you could
do this
um but once you click renew on the
advert it
takes your room right to the top of the
list
and bear in mind there's pages on pages
and pages
of rooms on spare room it takes you
right to the top
and that was brilliant because as soon
as i started to do that i started to get
more phone calls
fantastic so basically in leicester
there's hundreds of people looking for
rooms
but there's also hundreds of rooms
available so these hundreds of people
look for rooms and they just look at the
first few
it doesn't even cost anything to renew
it no it doesn't it doesn't cost
anything
renew it every single day get your
listing
at the top of spare room also list it on
other sites as well but
not just fair room stay on as many sites
as you can
fill your rooms fast because that's how
you get paid
i really hope you like this amazing
video and if you did please
smash the like button down here and if
you want to see more videos like this
please click up here please do us all a
favor and subscribe
right here yeah
[Music]